being born in the family I was and
everybody gave me such a hard time for
having a hard time being you know
Miley's little sister Noah Cyrus getting
candid about what it was like growing up
as Miley's little sister I always felt
like I was that person got no one kid
about due to what people said to me
online on Saturday the 20 year old
singer went live on Instagram to talk
about her new EP the end of everything
and got emotional talking about the
track young and sad a song she wrote
about growing up in her famous sister's
shadow
there's absolutely unbearable and that's
why I write I write my sister's like
sunshine always bringing good light
wherever she'll go then I was born to
rain clouds blessed in her shadows
because that's what everybody always
said to me that no matter what I was
gonna be a nut shadow Noah revealed that
she always believed that sentiment and
it's been so hard for her to overcome
that was something I heard my whole life
every single day my whole life and it
was either that or that I you know
wasn't enough in some way whether it was
the way I look or the way I am you know
like I said the other day I feel like
sometimes I don't even breathe right
sometimes and now that Noah's addressed
all that through music she doesn't want
to talk about it publicly ever again
basically that was what the songs about
and I just wanted to open up about that
once and for all because that's been a
big part of my life and I probably won't
talk about it anymore but I just wanted
to put it out and you know everybody
always says you're giving the people
power by seeing it but I can't control
seeing it you guys are young you know
the Internet it's been really tough on
me so this song that song is just pretty
tough to get through of course this
isn't the first time Noah has said all
she needs to say with the help of a
melody I didn't know how to communicate
in any other way but my music back in
2018 Noah opened up to ET about her EP
good cry every song was just from my
heart about this relationship and about
the way I was feeling she said the music
was heavily influenced by her breakup
with little Xan it's all honest like
there's nothing like you know I'm
talking about myself like I'm just
talking about the way that I'm feeling
and what I'm going through but I know a
lot of people from communicating with my
fans on Instagram we DM a lot I know
that they'll relate to this a lot
because a lot of my fans are young and
going through first loves nothing
compares to their first love or anything
of that sort that they can listen to
this album and they can turn to this
album and and find something and Noah
gave her famous dad Billy Ray Cyrus
props for teaching her so much about
music it's like I've been in music
school my whole life he inspires me a
time I sent him my records on really
yeah he and my mom I like the first
people I like sent her to my parents
they they obviously knew I was going
through a tough time in kind of every
aspect not knowing where I was going
musically but also personally and
through a relationship and they were
just super supportive and they loved
every song on the record and my dad is
my biggest fan and so is my mom